one of the funniest things about kamala
harris
she wasn't so so you mentioned her
calling you know
uh joe oh my gosh of this i know i know
i know
he he you didn't get you or anybody had
a chance to see it i don't care
that i get privy information so that's
right so this is yeah
you know you're doing it all right i'll
do it i'll do it so this is this is an
article from the hill saying
from harris i believe biden's accusers
so that means she was coming out that
and and agreeing with these people
that were accusing biden of
misconduct sexual misconduct
creepy joe creepy joe yeah well let's
let's let's my goodness i'm sorry man if
okay let me read this first before i
before i annihilate kamala
senator kamala kamala hara said tuesday
that she believes women who say they
felt uncomfortable after receiving
unwanted touching from former vice
president biden i believe them and i
respect them being able to tell their
story
and having the courage to do it the
california senator added
that biden will need to decide for
himself whether to run for president
he's going to have to make the decision
for himself i wouldn't tell him what to
do harris said
in recent days several women have come
forward to allege that biden has touched
them inappropriately
former nevada state lawmaker lucy flores
a democrat made the first accusation
last week in an essay
in new york magazine's the cut on monday
amy lapost told the hartford current
that biden also touched her
inappropriately at a 2009 fundraiser in
connecticut
two additional women caitlin caruso uh
and dj hill came forward tuesday sharing
their experiences with the new york
times
biden who is considering running for
president blah blah blah when was this
this was uh april of 2019. they say
he's considering running for presidents
has not commented publicly in the
accusation since sunday
when in response to flor's allegation he
said in a statement that he has offered
countless handshakes hugs expression of
affection
support and comfort and not once never
did i believe
i believe i acted inappropriately biden
added
if it is suggested i did so i will
listen respectfully
okay what did i do again joe biden
apologized
for touching children inappropriately
there was a big campaign where people
were saying things like
tell joe to stop touching these kids
because joe biden's got a problem
touching kids
and he talks about it have you seen this
photograph man
which one it's he's he's he's leaning
down next to a little boy
and he has his arm around the boy's face
and he's holding his hand over his mouth
and like
i think i'm pretty sure that's his
grandson that's still a creepy photo man
i absolutely i absolutely agree with you
like what was he doing i i don't know
it's worse
yeah it's worse that it's his grandson
have you seen him kiss his his
granddaughter or whatever on the left
who was it is his grandfather's
granddaughter yeah he kisses her on the
lips
i don't like that that's gross i think
creates me up
yeah man i mean listen i'll tell you
this
maybe there's some like family
convention you have like a tradition
where you kiss your grandchildren on the
lips
i know there's families that i've seen
that that do that
but i am not i'm not okay with it i'm
not i'm not a fan
and i'll tell you what you combine this
with these videos of joe biden
like have you seen what is it
joebiden.info or whatever is that is
that the website
no what are you talking about where it's
like just a bunch of videos of him
inappropriately touching kids
no i don't i don't really look for those
kind of things um
well it's a meme they tend to come
across my timeline and i'm just like oh
creepy joe add it again oh yeah here we
go here we go we got it we got it check
it out oh my goodness
so so we're gonna keep the focus on
kamala but i gotta show you this first
this is important
uncle joe for us senate joe biden is
back to take a hands-on
approach to america's problems biden has
a good feel for the american people
and can smell what they really want deep
down there's one for camella too
there is yeah check out our camel a
parody site kamala harris.info i'm
really curious i say joe is ready for a
fight
and we'll give a good old-fashioned
pounding to anybody who gets
in his way that's disgusting okay okay
hold on
the reason i bring this up is kamala
harris playing pr
says i i believe the women who who say
that joe
touched them inappropriately then joe
walks up and says want to be my running
mate she goes oh definitely
what that's how creepy this touch me joe
touch me i'm horrible no no it's it's an
issue of like
you've got all of these creepy
accusations you got
legit accusations against biden well and
we got video
of him touching children inappropriately
all the time like i've seen it with my
own eyes i don't care that he apologizes
he's a gross old man
this is great oh my goodness harris for
arresting the people this is kamala
harris.info
i love it we're gonna go we'll we'll
i've never i have not seen this yet i
haven't either and we'll come back to
biden oh this is great this is exactly
what we're talking about
captain non-violent criminals in jail to
put out forest fires yep
sort of early times when federal judges
in california wanted to expand its
prisoner release program for non-violent
criminals
kamala harris's lawyers argued against
it her lawyers claimed that releasing
them would cause prisons to lose an
important pool of forced labor for
putting out california's wildfires for
which the prisoners only get paid a
dollar an hour
wow and that was that's some serious
work too like
and dangerous work i'll be fair that's
insane
i'll be fair it was her office not her
personally
and now hold on i'm not finished okay
and also i'll be fair
do you think her administration would be
any different thank you these are the
people that she works with
and i think the only reason she was like
oh heavens me i didn't realize what they
were doing is because
she's protecting herself and throwing
them under the bus yep she didn't care
she knows these people here we go oh
this is a lot of what we already talked
about but it's great it's awesome
put parents in jail for children
skipping school and laughed about it
that's great what else we got opposed
dna testing that might get an innocent
black man off death throw
congratulations
defended the death penalty in 2014
federal judge in california ruled the
death penalty unconstitutional
despite having the ability as attorney
general to defend the ruling or stay out
of the matter entirely
kamala harris appealed it she claimed
the decision undermines important
protections
that our courts provide to defendants
now to be honest
i um as far as i understand
conservatives they're pro-death penalty
right
uh sometimes i mean didn't they just uh
reinstate the death penalty federally
under trump and bar i don't know
anymore about what conservatives right
right right
the line is blurring you see i look at
everything about kamala harris and i
really do view it from the left like all
and libertarian mind you i'm opposed
that's opposed to the death penalty i
look at kamala harris as
a despotic authoritarian completely
supported civil asset forfeiture to
seize property without any charges oh
man
i'm sure like every single libertarian
is like just fuming right now at this
choice
civil asset forfeiture allows police to
seize money property
and cars under a simple suspicion of
being used for criminal activity
despite no criminal charges countless
innocent people have been robbed under
this racket and police budgets have been
funded with the seized property
even though it is widely disliked and
arguably unconstitutional
kamala harris has publicly supported it
on multiple occasions she sponsored a
bill to allow
seizure of profits without charges and
in 2011 she opposed the bill
that would have reformed the procedure
and that's from jacobin
you know jacobin is no america's uh
foremost socialist magazine oh wow if
the socialists are complaining
that kamala harris is stealing people's
stuff you got a real problem here yeah
i love it opposed efforts to not report
juvenile undocumented immigrants to ice
i'm you know whatever i think that's
about it this is not kamala harris's
actual website and then you can shop
so share it yeah seriously wow this is
considered satire it says
yes that would be uh no these are actual
news stories from actual newspapers well
it's satire in the same way
babylon being the onion right write
these incredibly accurate things and
then a month later they come true
they're trying to uh highlight real
things she's done pretending to be for
her that's like the joke
i know it's great yeah it's hilarious
i'm gonna tell you about uh uh
i'm gonna tell you about joe biden it
looks like these are being made by
by lefties to be honest because i don't
think a conservative would complain
about her defending the death penalty
i can't imagine they would and i don't
know obviously not every single
conservative but right now i think
federally they're they're kicking back
up the death penalty
i am no fan of this at all i absolutely
oppose it it's it is a tough ethical
position but check this out they talk
about joe's legislative accomplishments
he's for mass incarceration i i oppose
that
he's against gay marriage i'm i'm
against that he's against abortion
rights
this is from the left the left is going
after biden and
kamala so how could they possibly win
they can't there's no way dude no
they're they're they're throwaways
it's a rebuild year i was joking when i
said it but it's absolutely true
right yeah they know they're gonna lose
democrats
i mean they they're gone
you've said months ago someone was
saying about how trump would be the last
republican president
i don't think that's the case i think
the democrats are are the ones that are
going to be gone
you know what man there was a period it
goes back and forth
based on what the news is right some
days you'll see things like this
and you're just like wow yeah that's it
how could they possibly win
now i see my normie friends people who
don't really pay attention and they get
they'll see passive memes
they're not paying attention to news i
can't stand that i feel like
you've got two different kinds of people
who are active in news and
it's like populist right versus populist
left for the most part
you do have crony establishment elites
who are relatively active and know
they're playing dirty games you know the
establishment democrats teaming up with
the establishment republic never trump
or republicans
but i i while i think many on the left
are incorrect in in their in their
information they're paying attention way
more than normies are
and i when i see my friend say things
like we all got to vote for biden i'm
like
uh you're for the iraq war you're for
death penalty and harsh drugs
you're against abortion you're for mass
incarceration look at the sources for
all this stuff
this is joe biden is a nasty dude yep
and you can
and he sniffs little girls
and now that he's appointed kamala
harris i'm just kind of like nah
man i don't know they're done
yeah so what what what what is this i
don't care i'm gonna pull out my popcorn
make a big huge bowl and watch those
debates it's gonna be delicious
i can't wait i love enter i love
watching good entertainment
and you gotta give it to trump he's an
entertainer man he's he's a good
president
and an entertainer he's going to be sad
i
laughed i know man i can't wait when
they announced
kamala harris and i i saw all the memes
i was laughing just non-stop everybody
was ready for this
right like trump had a video about phony
kamala ready to go boom right when they
announced it
dropped and here's the best part he was
in a press briefing apparently
when it wasn't when it was announced or
whatever and so he gets asked and trump
is trying to hold back laughing it was a
i i i started laughing when i saw his
face he made a face like this he's like
like trying not to laugh you know
because the reporter asked him
he asked him questions uh about kamala
harris being a hypocrite
like for instance she claimed that when
she was in college she listened to tupac
and snoop dogg
right but before they were famous before
that music even came out
oh okay and so everybody was like that
music didn't even exist when you were in
college you're talking about like she's
lying
and trump's like trying to hold back
laughing because here he is talking to
the white house press corps
who's usually very adversarial and
they're like mr president you put out an
ad
talking about kamal is a phony could you
comment on how she was a phony here here
and here and trump's just like
well yep there you go
but it was funny he was like he was like
what a what and they were like you
called her a phone and he goes oh
like his campaign did it you know trump
didn't realize they were dropping the
video well it came from
the trump like war room or like you know
the trump camp
right not from his direct account yeah
yeah so
so he's he's sitting there talking to
the press and he got i don't know who
asked him the question but man he got
teed up perfectly
like kamala harris is a phony she's
lying what was that what was that thing
where she
like she was asked about whether she
smoked or something oh yeah and then she
was like my family's jamaican
yeah i was actually uh trying to pull up
this
the story about her family about her dad
her dad was pissed i mean i could just
go off memory i was just reading about
this earlier and so she she basically
said to this reporter who was like well
did you do you ever smoke pot in high
school
and she goes wow half of my half my
family's jamaican what do you think
isis stereotype and then her dad comes
out
and and just as like your grandparents
like your family
me like we that's that is such a
terrible stereotype
that you know is not true that you know
he was pissed
so she she lied her family her the
jamaican side of her family they like
they don't like that whole stereotype
yeah because it's not movies it is you
know man
so he was pissed about it imagine
throwing your own family under the bus
to make a joke accusing your family of
being
stoners or smoking pot because you're
trying to
trick people into voting for you by
pretending to be
something that you are not she is the
last person sh
who should be given power yeah you got
it hold up
[Laughter]
should we oh yeah so so i i mean i found
this
and it seems to be true i mean this is
breitbart i mean
they they report on it so this this says
kamal's harris ancestors owned slaves
too
well i i got news for you but uh my
friend what kamala harris
is accused by the black community of not
being black
wow because she's indian and jamaican
yeah and so the washington post actually
writes this why some african americans
are questioning kamala harris's
blackness
and i'll give you the quick gist of it
it's really interesting
her her family i believe it's her dad
who was jamaican right
yeah and her her mom was an indian it
was her actually let me read it to make
sure i get it all right they say
online stories have actually hold on
this is from june 28th 2019.
online stories have circulated
suggesting the lawmaker is not
african-american
because her parents are immigrants and
she spent some of her childhood in
canada
during a february appearance on the
breakfast club radio show host dj envy
and charlemagne the god asked harris
about that
harris pushed back saying i'm black and
i'm proud of being black i was born
black i will die black she said
i am not going to make excuses for
anybody because they don't understand
she went on to criticize those who
question her racial identity racial
identity
she said i think they don't understand
who black people are i'm not going to
spend my time trying to educate people
about who black people are
because right now frankly i'm focused on
for example an initiative
that i have that is called the lyft act
that's about lifting folks out of
poverty
they go on to mention you know here here
we go they say
harris has had life experiences
different from those of many black
americans
her father is a jamaican immigrant her
mother is a tamil indian immigrant
her husband is a white man from new york
while she was born in oakland
a city with a rich history of
african-american activism harris spent
her early childhood in berkeley
california
and worshipped at a hindu temple in
addition to attending black baptist
services
she attended high school in montreal
before returning to the united states
for college at howard university
a historically black college these
differences may help explain
why some voters want to know more about
her background some want to know
that she understands some of the issues
affecting black americans since the
emancipation of slaves
harris has said that she supports
reparations for the descendants of black
people who are enslaved in america
but those asking more questions have
attempted to explain the intentions
behind their inquiries
basically well i'll read the quote this
whole argument
is that uh that we're saying she's not
black is really ridiculous yvette
carnell co-founder of the american
descendants of slavery movement
are say uh we are saying there is a
difference in the justice demands for
people who are descendants of slaves in
this country
and those who are enslaved in jamaica
cornell fleshed out the argument further
and in a tweet kamala harris doesn't
have that in her lineage
she's anchored in two different
immigrant parents it's really simple
since kamala harris doesn't have the
experience in her background or a track
record that expresses
this understanding and she announced
during mlk week at howard university
of course she's going to get pressed
hard on the specificity
of her [ __ ] agenda they say adios's
american descendants of slavery
so i'll put it simply man she's
literally not african
okay and then wait and what you just
said i i don't know where that just
disappeared down here the [ __ ]
yeah yeah american defense this one
right so but but above this
it was saying we're saying there's a
difference
in the justice demands for people who
are descendants of slaves in this
country and those who are enslaved in
jamaica
enter wherever
this is from her own father talk donald
harris
it's actually from the free beacon so
breitbart is just quoting the free
beacon okay so donald harris says he's a
stanford university economics professor
revealed in 2018 that his grandmother
was a descendant of hamilton brown
the namesake of brownstown in northern
jamaica my roots go back
quote within my lifetime to my paternal
grandmother
miss crishy i might have said that wrong
but uh it's a christina brown
yeah her maiden name christina brown oh
christina bound descendant of hamilton
brown who was on record as a plantation
and slave owner
and founder of brownstown so he this is
her own father
saying that they're just they're
descendants of slave owners
this is the problem with the weird
leftist identity politics stuff
kamala harris is she's not african you
she can say she's black and old stuff
because i'm
far be it for me to tell anybody about
what any of that stuff represents
i'll defer to other people but it it
looks like this let me let me see if i
can pull up the free beacon
it looks like there it is washington
free beacon kamala harris's ancestors
owned slaves her father said
now i am i am not going to punish kamala
for the sins no no of course
right right and that that's one of the
big problems we have but
think about what she's claiming and
trying to represent
versus what her history actually is both
her parents are immigrants she has
that does not go beyond amer you know
into american ancestry pertaining to
slaves
nor she was not a victim of nor
perpetrator of anything having to do
with that american history yep now there
is i think it's fair to point out
it's possible that she i think it's
likely was a victim of racial
discrimination and
in probably various forms these things
happen and
you know that that's that's fair to
point out would you take a look at her
history
and that flies in the face of what she's
claiming to represent for sure
it's the it's the inversion of what
these other people were saying about her
and then a lot of the arguments in
defense of kamala ignored what they were
actually saying
they were like how silly to claim that
kalama isn't really black that's so
stupid
and that's the media's gang instead of
being honest and
and showing you know the washington post
mind you did a good job but a lot of the
pundits
a lot of these politicos and pundits try
and excuse the game they play
instead of saying straight up what
they're actually talking about is that
she is not
a descendant of slavery she does not
have this experience
she went to high school in montreal she
grew up in a
very uh uh you know uh activist-y area
in berkeley
yeah she is not somebody who experienced
say the hardships of chicago or new york
or any one of these other places she
actually had it pretty good it sounds
yep well she can she's gonna of course
play
she's gonna play that card that's that's
that's the modern identity politics that
we get right now
with people like kamala harris and the
democrats you know
ben shapiro tweeted something it was
interesting he called her far left
okay and people immediately were like
immediately were like she is
not far left she is more of these kind
of like corporate centrist
authoritarians
but then ben shapiro came back out and
said actually
and he posted a list of all the things
she's endorsed and it would seem like
the way i would put it is she's
desperately trying to pander
to the progressives and the crazy thing
to me about
choosing you're right a recovery year is
that what's called a rebuild
a rebuild a rebuild that's like what was
that like when a sports team yeah when
the sport like in uh
1998 when the bulls kind of were coming
today
they lost their in the last dance they
talk about how they're gonna do a
rebuild year which is because they
they get so big that they can't afford
to pay all their players
right because all the players are now
worth their championship winners
yeah so they have to trade them off so
that they can save money to then
you know rebuild that's this is uh this
is the democrats rebuild
so they've it makes sense man it really
does
the interesting things i've i've heard
the argument made before that they don't
actually think they're going to win
but why is that why are the polls
claiming going to win is this like
they're going for a b team but hoping
that they
they can win off of like past
recognition or or hate for trump
you know what i mean i i don't know part
of me
thinks that they maybe still think that
they can actually win
because of the way that they're pushing
it all out like they they're act they're
playing the part like they're trying
to win but everything about kamala is
like
she's horrible horrible harris seriously
and i i
i don't know why anyone would want to
defend her and let her be
this close to being president she's a
terrible woman i tweeted this out and i
know it's a joke all right
let's let's so this is the the cop
kamala meme
it's funny and i i really don't think
that
conservatives are going to you know look
at this
and get a kick out of it i do i view the
criticism much like a lot of these other
people coming from the left like
she's an authoritarian despotic
individual now personally
i think this this photo is hilarious i
don't think all cops are bad like you
know a lot of these far left just like
to claim
but why would the left who characterize
her in this way
ever give their support to this woman
the only the only reason in my opinion
they would choose kamala is because
they're like
let's burn it down like like joe biden's
sleeping in the wheelchair with a
blanket over his hips in the sun
and there's some people sitting there
going like i'm bored you want to start a
fire
yeah that's literally what many of these
antifa types are doing and they're like
they're bored and lighting fires yeah
exactly
and they're like hey hey kamala come
down here why
we're gonna burn it down and she's like
ooh i'm down no she's thinking like oh i
can lock them all up
yes no no that's she's totally oblivious
they're like you want to burn everything
down like yeah hey kamal you want to be
the running mate she's like oh i do and
she runs and they're all laughing
yeah i'm seeing all of these tweets from
from many on the left
there was uh there's a really famous
viral post from the progressive
personality kyle kalinski
okay and he said something like i'm not
he said
he said i'm not going to be supporting
the democratic ticket so if you want to
blame me
for you know costing the election by all
means do so please
something that affects who's basically
saying like do it do it claim claim i'm
the one
because they need people like him to
actually win
and so for a while it made sense what
biden was doing yeah
he biden was was was the vp in an
administration
for a president they called the deporter
in chief nope they criticized joe biden
over this
then when joe biden's debating bernie
he's like i'm calling for a moratorium
on
on uh deportations you know and and and
you know decriminalizing border
crossings look
it's like wow that's that's a 180 from
where you were under the obama
administration
it made sense he was trying to pander to
a far left but i'll tell you what man
you can't win that right nope because
the far left
and and regular liberals are too far
apart it creates this huge
gap you can't you can't get them all
disagree i mean the far left doesn't
like liberals they rag them all the time
so it's real not all of them but but the
more radical ones
so so then i guess the idea was do a 180
they start embracing trump's positions
like buy american buy back better
buy build back better build back better
there it is guys
it's just it's make america great again
you can't beat it
yup trump's got it already it's too late
didn't he try like
he made something that said like buy
american plan or something yeah yeah
man that's ridiculous yeah i've told you
he's trying to cater to
the trump fans that the people who you
know
are like you know what trump's trump's
doing it right he's like oh man how can
i
oh build back better that's that's
basically the same thing right and uh
buy american
act that's that's it that's crazy to me
it's like
they're they're that this is why i was
saying early on you know the cons
my my mind snapped when i was like he
really did it he really picked kamala
they must want trump to win yeah i can't
explain it i'm sorry
because i don't think i don't think a
human being could i think if you were
that stupid
you wouldn't you wouldn't have like you
would be able to breathe properly like
you'd be so dumb you wouldn't be able to
coordinate your movements to actually
walk around
but but you think i'm joking you think
i'm joking no no listen let's go back in
time
okay russia gave bloop in their faces
yep that trump ended up raising
record amounts of money when that was
proven to be bs true then they go for
another scan they go for impeachment
or that they have uh the whistleblower
and ukraine gate
right trump raises record amounts of
money they do impeachment trump
raises records about record amounts of
money after impeachment failed
trump's approval rating skyrockets i'm
like how is it
that every single time they help trump
how dumb do you have to be so they just
can't get it i don't think they're dumb
and i think you mentioned something
about this last night you were talking
about how he uh
no matter what trump does what no matter
what trump does he's wrong
right so even a broken clock is right
twice a day right so
the democrats are doing everything wrong
right no no no no no they've gotten
absolutely nothing right they would be
right at least a couple times at least
here and there
no but they have been there oh really
yes what's that uh the left
when they shut down trump's press events
on kovid
because it was benefiting him thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode